Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video io sono Favij e
per concludere l'anno facciamo una
Reaction Mamma mia Sono nel mio studio
non faccio più video nello studio
praticamente nella cioè nel mio studio a
casa però adesso lo sto usando soltanto
per suonare il Launchpad ma non faremo
video di questo che non faccio Reaction
e robe di questo tipo qua però ci sono
dei momenti in cui necessitano Flavio
Savino animazioni un canale YouTube che
fa co co fa cose e io non ho visto
nessuno di questi video lo sono aperto
uno a metà Già solo le copertine
meritano la Reaction potrei fare un
video solo facendo Reaction alle
copertine ma senza tetto ha sposato un
Milionario parliamo questo che mi sembra
abbastanza onesto Allora 3 2 1 vamos Non
vedo l'ora
ma ho trovato mio marito in una pila di
rifiuti
è già Il video potrebbe finire qua non
ho capito
Ma poi scusa Fai la pancia che è
trasparente Cioè questo è è un
superpotere ma ho trovato mio marito in
una pila di rifiuti va bene aperto gli
occhi si è subito tappato il naso
ammetto di non aver proprio un bel
profumo Ma figurati lui che stava nella
spazzatura Invece qui profumerà proprio
di Chanel Ciao a tutti mi chiamo Alice e
ho 25 Ciao ciao i miei genitori sono
morti in un incidente stradale e la
banca ha confiscato la mia casa è così
che sono finita per strada quel giorno
ho visto quel tipo buttar via il cartone
di una pizza una pizza avanzata né
spuntava e mi chiamava ma poi è svenuto
sono cose io ho controllato il polso si
sentiva malapena ho iniziato a fargli
rianimazione e respirazione bocca a
bocca come a casa mia questa è
rianimazione bocca a guancia però però
vabbè ha insegnato la mia defunta mamma
che faceva l'interno
poveretto ecco chi ero la sua ragazza o
almeno è quanto detto al dottore
sorpreso per poter restare in ospedale e
riscaldarmi
il giorno seguente ho rivisto Tommaso lo
salutato ma lui mi ha urlato contro ho
scoperto venerdì mattina la sua
fidanzata era venuta a trovarlo in
ospedale era stato detto che lui era
stato salvato dal suo insegnante no ma
questo è sbagliato
ha rovinato una relazione per una fetta
di pizza non si fa tranne se era una
bufala in quel caso va bene Luana Questo
era il nome della fidanzata
Tommaso perché aveva fatto amicizia con
una schifosa mendicante non penso fosse
quello il motivo credo il motivo fosse
perché pensava che fossi l'amante
semplicemente Però vabbè che ingrato il
minimo che potresti fare offrirmi un
caffè hai rovinato il mio matrimonio la
mia promessa sposa pensava che
frequentassi una barbona ma non è il
problema della barbona Il problema è che
frequentassi un'altra donna
a prescindere dalle condizioni
economiche Cioè se stavi frequentando
con un'altra ragazza ma non riuscivo a
dimenticare Tommaso cinque mesi dopo
quando sono entrata in travaglio Ho
bussato alla sua porta nel cuore della
notte e mezz'ora dopo mi stava portando
di corsa in ospedale Sulla sua auto ho
avuto una femminuccia la bambina più
bella e sfortunata del mondo dopo il
parto Tommaso veniva a trovarmi
regolarmente ha pagato tutte le mie
spese e poi ha condotto Ma basta questa
basta capire cosa stesse accadendo Ma
Tommaso mi ha spiegato che quel giorno
aveva visto Luana in ospedale voleva
abortire non so chi sia il padre e
nemmeno mi importa ha detto a Luana
non so chi sia il padre e nemmeno mi
importa Ma cosa vuol dire Cosa vuol dire
hai dato della barbona ti sei fatta
coerenza Ti prego nella vita Santo Iddio
già c'hai la testa ovale Porca vacca
ma mi ha dimostrato di non essere in
grado di costruire una famiglia felice
con me ma ora so chi voglio avere il mio
fianco ed è così che ho trovato una casa
e un marito eh
Mamma mia raga bellissima Secondo me
possiamo trovare di meglio ancora
l'amante di mio marito mi ha resa madre
di 8 figli
cioè sono allora allora
hanno questo questo non ha i test questa
non ha il doppiaggio lo faccio io sono
rimasto incinta dopo aver buttato via di
nascosto gli atti concezionali e già
questo non si fa Riccardo non voleva
figli ma io ne desideravo tanto uno
magari non smetti di prenderli senza
dirglielo è questo che cos'è un iperplag
anale o è una lampada non lo sappiamo
andiamo avanti ragazzi
dall'ecografia ho scoperto che l'avremo
avuti cinque non ci stanno Cioè cosa sei
un elefante cosa volevo fare una
sorpresa Riccardo ma è venuta a mancare
all'improvviso Eh beh certo cioè avere
abbastanza soldi per crescere 5 figli
Riccardo ne ha mentito ed ero
completamente al verde 0 così conto 0
sul foglio per sbeffeggiarla quelli
della banca no Un giorno tre bambini
sconosciuti sono venuti a casa mia certo
aggiungiamo pure Harry Potter e Ron
Weasley alla trama perché tanto mancava
solo quello riusciva a capire cosa
stesse succedendo sono i figli di del
tipo di prima che è morto per la prima
volta la morte di Riccardo ho tirato
fuori il suo telefono aveva già una
famiglia quindi lui c'erano le foto di
quei bambini Riccardo aveva un amante e
tre figli minchia e mandava loro
regolarmente nel denaro i bambini erano
affamati a piangevano poverini e ci sei
tu Ma non li ho lasciati entrare in casa
perché sei proprio stronzo però diciamo
lasciamoli fuori la pioggia volevo
chiamare la polizia dei servizi sociali
ho capito almeno falli entrare sti
Christian poverini Ma scusa
è cascata ma l'improvviso mi sono
sentita male e loro hanno pure aiutata
Dimmi di no perché non te lo meriti ero
sola e non c'è nessuno ad aiutarmi
attenzione
colpo di scena mi sono svegliato in
ospedale con i miei cinque figli
c'è un incredibile vero Ok
se non avessero chiamato Aiuto Non ce
l'avreste fatta
volevo ringraziare i piccoli per avermi
salvata loro che è sempre che piangono
poi verranno stati portati in una casa
famiglia no come
la loro madre gli aveva abbandonati pure
e c'è sempre un complottista continuo
Quindi ho deciso di adottarli va bene
Sono diventata la loro tutrice
c'hai veramente un sacco di bambini poi
ho scoperto che avevano un conto in
banca Minchia Riccardo aveva messo da
parte per loro molti soldi alla fine
gira tutto attorno i soldi raga' voglio
essere madre di almeno un bambino
volevo serrare almeno un bambino ma lo
sono diventata di molti e ora sono
felicissima perché otto volte più amore
è affetto da dare
io certi comportamenti Meravigliosa
donna No Concetta no certi comportamenti
non idonei nella vita di un credente ci
fanno riflettere un marito infedele non
può compromettere l'amore verso i suoi
figli brava questa mamma che non ha
lanciato la sua pietra per condannare ma
al soccorso con il suo amore chi era nel
bisogno Gloria al nostro Dio ha un
pubblico particolare questo canale qua
Abbiamo un pavimento rotto mi ha aiutato
a trovare marito il mio peso ha sfondato
un pavimento in cemento
Ecco le case abusive il mio peso ha
sfondato un pavimento in cemento ma poi
tra l'altro c'è sulle Scusatemi ragazzi
sto Stoppa però sul letto cioè questa si
è seduta sul letto e il letto è caduto
al piano di sotto sono caduta sul mio
vicino e l'ho reso disabile ero
mortificata ma lui mi ha invitata a cena
come puoi invitare a cena una ragazza
dandole una barretta dice Vuoi venire a
cena e le dai una barretta di cioccolato
le cose sono andate avanti ma non
eravamo mai soli Sì Flavia è il mio
mentore spirituale Ah non è la madre
presto lei ci ha sposati
Flavia è una granny stalker mi sono
sentita male e sono rincasata prima
Flavia e il paralizzato Dino stavano
saltando sul letto mi sembra veramente
il poco paralizzato Dino Ehi ciao Esco
dai principi della Pietà Ma la Pietà di
questi due si è rivelata una menzogna si
è spinta troppo oltre È il suo cuore
per non morire dovevo operarmi ma avevo
dei Risparmi Oh no Dino si era preso
tutti i miei soldi oppure li ha presi
dal comodino No dai Dino viveva alla
grande con i miei soldi Ciao [ __ ]
No perché rivoglio indietro i miei soldi
o morirò me li hai dati tu stessa
stupida ma di non si è tradito
ha segato una panchina in attesa di una
nuova vittima
era stato lui a manomettere il soffitto
ma sto male il tuo grasso mi ha
paralizzato Mi dispiace farò di tutto
per farla guarire
il ragazzo e mostrato le prove contro
Dino aveva manomesso anche il mio
pavimento era una truffa Stefano ha
pagato la mia operazione non potevo
crederci avviene si vedono in prigione
prego Fatemi conoscere lo sceneggiatore
ne ho bisogno comunque Ragazzi ho
trovato il mio nuovo canale preferito e
non sto scherzando ve lo giuro faviosa
animazioni voglio fare altre Reaction
perché sono storie pazzesche Vi
ringrazio per avermelo consigliato io
veramente non so come ho fatto a vivere
senza finora cioè veramente non vedo
l'ora di guardarle tutte ma per adesso
ci fermiamo qua Vi ringrazio ci vediamo
al prossimo video ragazzi iscrivetevi al
canale e fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate
Beh bella ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi